He stubs his toe. He goes, "Oh, it's the snark community." Which,
by the way, he says, "I'm a part of." Bro, this is literally
This is literally the most Israel coded story of all time, dude.
He's decided to bury all of the people that have dared to criticize
him under costly litigation while simultaneously claiming falsely
that they were responsible for child protective services being
called house.
Um, [music] Moist Critical has
taken to uh the H3H3 versus Idubbbz lawsuit. Now, you guys already
know some of the details. Um, Ethan Klein, H3H3, former uh fair
use precedent setting. Uh, Ethan Klein, former podcast host of
m co-host of mine uh who's been on a tear. Uh, basically trying
to wrap up all of the people that he feels he's been wronged
by with frivolous lawsuits as a vacious litigant has done it
again. Um, he's done a whole video or he he's launched another
lawsuit this time against Idubbbz, former friend of Ethan Klein
as well.
Not a terrible job. Good submar solid >> Posted a a statement
not from Idubbbz, mind you. A statement from Destiny
um sex pesty who uh once alleged that Ethan had his own children
and that child protective services should be uh called to his
home.
It's okay. So, I do want to say I don't agree with what's being
said in this um comment here.
Uh, but I I'm putting it on screen because I think it should
be addressed because it's a big bold accusation that's very up.
>> And it was actually really interesting that a lot of
YouTubers that normally would have been uh collectively very
critical of Ethan uh launching these frivolous lawsuits uh and
and and turning litigation into content and potentially even
overwriting the uh previous president that he himself fought
for. Um they were they were nowhere to be found and I think part
of that is because the people that Ethan had chosen to attack
were unpopular. That's just the reality of the matter. They're
unpopular on the internet. I myself am one of those figures [laughter]
um in the dramas sphere in the drama ecosystem.
>> And it's like there's no
I understand that people are like, "Oh, Hassan wants to make
this about politics and it's not explain the like him not suing
Destiny
in the same way he sued these other people." Like you you literally
can't explain it through anything other than well, we have political
alignment, right?
I guess you could say maybe they were friends at some point.
I don't dude I don't even believe that anymore though. I I'm
sure I can find another example of people who were friends and
people who have become critical of him. I really do think it's
like
maybe it's not about politics per se. It's about people who called
him out for not taking a strong stance on Israel. Anybody who
did that, anybody who wouldn't defend him on the Israel thing
is someone who's a target system. There are established enemies
that unite all of the reactionary bases and also even the centrist
accounts. Um and and oh wait, hold on. Drama ecosystem. There
are established enemies that unite all of the reactionary bases.
They were they were no one of those. And I think part of that
is because the people that Ethan had chosen to attack were unpopular.
That's just the reality of the matter. They're unpopular on the
internet. And I myself am one of those figures. >> Yeah.
That's what I think of the guy who's streaming to like 25,000
30,000 people every day. Unpopular on the >> I don't know
if Charlie took a
I don't know what kind of stance Charlie took
uh in this uh you know in this in this piece that he did, but
I I do find it odd that they didn't cover the the Dennis lawsuit.
I do find it odd that they didn't cover the other uh uh instances
of litigation, but uh let's see what he had to say. >> Pugilistic
legal paperwork has been filed against Idubbbz. So now they're
going to duke it out. Not with knuckle sandwiches, but with extremely
expensive litigation. Offer before I even get into this video
and meatballs of the actual story here. There is just something
that pets my thieves. There is something that grinds my gears,
greases my cheeks so much I can't resist yapping about it briefly.
When I was in the trenches digging around for information about
>> Why are we defending a man who does not venue you? I
don't I'm not in the business of of uh you know transaction
Ah come on. Why dude that's such a that's a H3 a spiritual H3
chatter right there. Why defend somebody who won't defend you?
Because I have principles cuz like I principally on these lines
I don't want this to happen. Right.
Even people you hate the most. I had like five minutes I was
totally I I thought it was really funny that Destiny maybe five
t minutes where I thought it was it was really funny that Destiny
lost his monetization because of the Charlie Kirk thing. It's
like well yeah
I guess I don't want anybody losing their YouTube monetization
because of that me even though I think he should lose it for
other reasons. It probably has to happen through the right channels
or else obviously if this is just allowed to happen and people
are fine with it. It's
hell man because there's always been like an unwritten rule on
the internet not just YouTube where if there's beef online it
stays online and you handle it online without you know going
over that threshold the event horizon of trying to use litigation
to silence your opponent or something like that. That had always
been etched in the stone tablets of Ten Commandments of online
discourse. >> True. And now all of a sudden I'm hearing
about H3 suing Idubbbz for defamation. So obviously I wanted
to hear more about that. And after diving in, hitting that cannonball
into the pool, I learned he has a lot of active lawsuits. I think
it's five maybe six against other streamers and YouTubers. So
it's it's a bit of a rampage he's been on. I knew about one before
all this, which was against the snark community that I did hear
about. And that one >> snark community >> made a
lot of sense to me actually. >> Oh. Oh, the snark the snark
community. >> The snark community from what I recall was
doing some diabolical like >> Yeah. This is like uh to
be look listen are there annoying people on the internet that
are up people's asses all the goddamn time. Absolutely. Okay.
Ethan Klein operates a snark community against myself.
>> I don't think any of Ethan Klein's lawsuits are even
in any way, shape, or form remotely defensible. He has obviously
postured it and positioned it in a way where it comes across
as defensible to other content creators by claiming a litany
of different insane things that he claims were happening because
people were gangstalking him and and uh I don't know like going
after his family and like sending CPS and sending skulls to his
house or whatever. Okay, I don't know the veracity of these claims,
but I do know one thing. He has used that as a counter to every
single goddamn thing. He stubs his toe. He goes, "Oh, it's the
snark community." Which, by the way, he says I'm a part of. All
of his all of the people that he has actively sued, he has claimed
were responsible without any evidence whatsoever for sending
child protective services to his house, to sending uh skulls
to his house. Like it's an incredible it's an incredible method.
Meanwhile, I'm literally being prosecuted by the goddamn federal
government allegedly and these guys are celebrating that decision.
And at no point did I ever turn around and say, "Oh, Ethan Klein
is the reason why I have a subpoena from the government." Okay.
It's ridic.
It's It is really funny because that is the logic Ethan is using,
right? Basically, these people don't like me. They haven't liked
me and I don't like criticism. Well, I won't even include that.
They don't like me and then something bad happened to me. Anybody
who's a part of the group that doesn't like me, I can go after
in any way I possible is like what he's green lit for himself.
>> So, you can have this like totally neurotic
like just
drop of a hat, you can go after anybody you want. That's what
he think that's the environment Ethan Klein is making for himself
intentionally because he wants to be able to go after everybody,
right?
He wants it to he wants everyone who's going to criticize him,
everyone who's going to say something mean about him, he wants
them thinking twice that he might sue them for it, right?
That's really what he's going for here. That is his goal the
whole time. I need to make sure that I can go after anybody here.
I need to make sure that I can if you are coming after me in
any way and again I you wouldn't want to draw any parallels to
like the real world but who sort of
who just sort of like hits their
just to remind them that being in opposition to them is going
to get them like killed or bombed at some point. Who does this?
Who does this kind of thing? WHO WELL, WE DON'T WANT TO DRAW
ANY, you know, real world allegory here. No analogies to the
real world. Okay. Nope. Nope. No, no, no. Don't do that. Don't
do that. Don't do that. Don't do that. That would be that would
be insane. That would be nuts. >> Celebrate that decision
by the federal government, which they have openly, which is also
disgusting. Doesn't mean that they had anything to do with it.
>> And like, by the way, what you could say here is, yeah,
it's possible that because of, you know, Hassan derangement on
the internet, somebody from one of these communities works in
government, they file like a report in some way or they they
talk to somebody they know. Like, do you know what I mean? It's
it's technically possible through some chain of causality that
somebody Ethan, Destiny, one of these people doing content on
Hassan led to him being
You know what that doesn't necessarily mean? That Hassan can
go after anybody who's critical of him. That he could just whoever
he wants, he can sue them. He can with them in any way he wants.
That's what it doesn't mean.
But it's ridiculous to be like, "Yeah, I'm suing anonymous Redditors
on the internet because I believe that they're coordinating like
a mass harassment campaign against me and and therefore like
in order for a lot of these people in order for a lot of these
people to understand, yeah, he is a he is a snarker of mine.
He is, which is, you know, whatever. It is what it is." But in
order for a lot of these people who have been in support of these
decisions, in support of Ethan's uh vexacious litigant status,
in order for them to come to terms with how frivolous these lawsuits
are, I should probably start doing the exact same thing so they
can be on board with the opposition. All of a sudden, they'll
probably understand it. Can you imagine if I were going after
random anonymous accounts over and over again trying to create
this conspiracy claiming that they were the reasons why they
were responsible for why uh you know I was I was getting uh uh
pursued by the federal government. Oh, I I got banned by the
United Kingdom because of Ethan Klein and anonymous Redditors.
Can you imagine if I tried to launch lawsuits against anonymous
Redditors and try to dox them going after Reddit mods and then
on top of that going after all of these people that have done
like a million articles, a million YouTube videos on me in many
instances genuinely actually slandering me too, defaming me actively.
claiming I offer material support to terrorist groups. Material
support for terrorism is a literal crime. You are definitionally
slandering me and claiming that I'm engaging in a literal crime
if defamation per se
>> supporting. Yeah, I mean technically
>> does he have a point that like they're basically they
are making him run a foul of an actual he might actually have
a point.
That's crazy. Now, I I don't think that that means you would
sue all these people. By the way, even though they are accusing
you of this, even if he even if he was charged with it, I don't
think you'd necessarily sue the people who are who are saying,
"Well, you because it just to me it overlaps way too much with
just normal speech." Technically, it is illegal to give aid to
terrorist groups. When you say he supports terrorist groups,
it is kind of making him run a foul of the law. I would never
support that lawsuit. I don't think that would be okay at all
to be honest with you. definitionally slandering me and claiming
that I'm engaging in a literal crime. If I were to go after every
single YouTuber, half of the YouTube commentary sphere would
receive lawsuits. Okay? Every single one of these people that
have defended Ethan Klein's ridiculous lawsuits, uh, claiming
that it was actually the the utmost, uh, uh, claiming that these
lawsuits were like unironically maintaining the integrity of
the commentary sphere, not realizing that if those lawsuits were
actually pursued, that there would be a new president that would
destroy fair use. Guess what? Guess what? Even when I jokingly
reference it, every single one of those people that were in defense
of Ethan's lawsuits turned around and started railing on me,
saying, "Oh my god, Assan can't take criticism at all." Maybe
it's not a joke. Yeah, it's not a joke. I maintain the position
that maybe more Pegasus is not uh uh you know, maybe he might
be uh receiving a lawsuit [clears throat] or legal action sometime
soon. But like my point is this. My point is this. Ethan actually
did sue people. Kane his ass. Kane his ass now.
Okay. I he hit quite a few he hits some decent points there that
it's like very very weird that it's Pegasus and and sensitive
society getting all mad. They all get super angry, super ass
mad when Hassan talks about possibly when he goes over some laws
and talks about possibly suing this guy and it's like yeah we
just wanted that response from before.
Like can't you retroactively apply that? Doesn't that retroactively
apply? I still think Assange shouldn't do it. I would still say
do not do that obviously. I think even menacing it is bad.
It ends up coming out in the wash a little bit with exposing
the hypocrisy, but I still think it's bad to even like threaten
it or intimate it. You are sort of like soft pushing people off
of covering you. Now,
I would never stop, you know, I would never stop covering somebody
because they intimated they might sue me. You know what I'm saying?
But many people >> Okay. As Charlie here is is openly recognizing,
he did. He actually sued and he even destroyed the livelihoods
of Caseyron and and even got a default on the Morgan case as
well. All of those cases were frivolous.
But the people that he was litigating, the people that he was
suing did not have the the financial backing to pursue a long
and costly litigation process. So they had to default or they
had to actually concede to the unbelievable demands that he was
making. Demands such as an ISIS hostage style video that he forced
Casey trying to read that those very same people turned around
and claimed the the very same people in the commentary sphere
claimed was valid, claimed was awesome. Well, you see, they just
thought it was Dude, he does hit it just precisely.
They're just like valid targets to other people for no reason.
It's It totally defies principle. It's up. They're just valid
targets. It's man, it's just a way to be. >> Yeah. He's
accused multiple people of CPS. He said different streamers,
editors, and chatters have all sent CPS to his house without
any proof. Apparently, you literally asked him if he has any
proof. The smart community sent CPS and he said, "No, I have
never said that." Yeah. Remember that? Remember when I talked
to him in person in that disastrous I guess you could call it
a debate if you want to call it that where I was like what proof
what evidence do you have that like my
it was a debate. It was like a four-hour debate. It was like
an epic debate. Epic in terms of the scale I made right. What
do you mean if you could call it that? If you call it that. Of
course we call it that. It was a massive debate. You guys were
a pair of debate lords. >> Myself and all these other people
have actually sent child protective services to your house. Like
where is this coming from? Cuz he was claiming everyone in their
mothers was responsible for calling child protective services.
I didn't even know that was happening and they were saying I
was responsible for it. He genuinely sincerely in the most like
schizophrenic way thinks that there's a network a coalition of
people that are in constant collaboration with one another that's
like actively trying to ruin his life not realizing that there
is a coalition of people that are actively ruining his life.
It's just that those people are in support of Ethan Klein or
at least seemingly in support of Ethan Klein using him and his
FINANCIAL STATUS TO
WHAT hold on
is
I'm just like blushing. Is he
who who would tell him that? Who would say that? Who would say
that? There's like, oh, it's totally schizophrenic for you to
allege that there's this group of people all coordinating against
you in some way with no proof whatsoever. Who would ever Who
would ever say that? Who would ever Come on, man.
Co. Come on.
That Sorry, I'm just laughing to myself a little bit. Hassan's
making me blush. He's He's got the talking points. >> They're
actively ruining his life. >> He's watched a couple streams.
He knows all about it. That's probably the number one reason
I think I could get sued is I think people would ask for my DMs
with Assan if I did get sued. You know what I mean? They'd be
like, "We need to see your DMs with Assan now." And those are
private. We have those in a Signal chat that disappears every
30 minutes. You'll never get those. Those DMs, you'll never find
them. Okay? Those DMs are in a disappearing chat on Signal like
Lauren De Lagona taught me. Thank you. Shout out Lauren De Lagona.
It's just that those people are in support of Ethan Klein, or
at least seemingly in support of Ethan Klein, using him and his
financial status to pursue people that they don't like on the
internet, to constantly goat him into litigation after litigation,
telling him that he's doing the right thing over and over again,
telling him that he actually should pursue these people and bury
them in financial uh financial troubles through costly litigation.
Those are the people who are actively going into his community
acting as though they're lifelong fans and using him like a local
>> But of course, it's impossible.
>> They are using him like a local weapon. That is another
Jesus. This guy's like spitting today. I have it sped up, but
I don't even know. Huzzan's actually making really great points
on this. Dude, this guy missed his calling as a snarker. I'm
telling you, this guy, this guy's so much better at drama than
he is at politics. It's really unfortunate. He's like forced
tragically to be a political activist when his true calling was
just to be like the real Nicholas Dioro, who Nicholas Dioro wanted
to be. That was that was Hassan's true calling in life was to
be leading the commentary sphere on YouTube. And instead he's
got to go and be a
instead he's got to go be like some kind of political activist.
This total >> to get him to understand this because he's
far too paranoid at this point. >> Harassing, stalking
stuff, sending CPS. I remember remember that and like human skulls.
Those things I recalled from like the smart community. So it
made sense that he would pursue litigation there cuz that is
highly illegal psychopath behavior. So that one I remember and
that one made sense. Like >> I don't even disagree with
the premise if there was any veracity to these
Right. Yeah. Like whoever sent skulls this guy's house is a psycho.
Whoever sent them, right? That person's a psycho. Whoever called
CPS probably a psycho. Like I'm saying probably a psycho. As
in there's probably one case like there might be a case where
somebody like genuinely is um like unwell and they they're like,
"Oh, this is very serious. His kids are eating dogs. I have to
call now." But that could be because of him. It could be because
of Snark. It could be because of bad epidata. Who knows? But
I it's either that person's a psycho or they're genuinely like
not really able to discern that this is sort of tongue and cheek.
You know what I mean? Anyway,
former housekeeper that would be psycho to call CPS on somebody.
I know everybody says it's the nanny that they let go. I still
would call count that as a psycho, but again, we just don't know
who it was. Okay. If there was any proof if there was any proof
of like coordinated messaging where people were just like, "Yes,
let's go. Let's send child protective services house," then yeah,
it's it's valid. The problem is none of his lawsuits have anything
to do with that. None of his lawsuits have anything to do with
that at all. He really thinks he's going to crack this case.
He he thinks there's like like all these people on the internet
are all out. He doesn't think this. He doesn't care about who
called CPS. He literally doesn't care at all. This is just about
basically the environment where it became okay to make fun of
him. He's going to attack everybody who participates in that
environment.
That's more what it is. Okay. out to get him and they're trying
to [__] actively ruin his life, not realizing that
the only person ruining Ethan Klein's life is Ethan Klein. Okay?
>> His his paranoia is the reason why people don't [__]
with him anymore. And the the the
frivolous lawsuits that he's launched against his opposition
is part of the reason why people don't [__] with
him anymore. His opinions on Israel is part of the reason why
people don't [__] with him anymore.
He was accusing everyone of CPS. Only when Denim said he's suing
him, he
>> Uh I want to address something from Denim's uh correction
demand in her letter. The letter claims I falsely stated that
Denims herself filed the proceeding CPS report or that Denims
caused others to do so. The letter also states on March 11th,
I acknowledged Denims had denounced herself or anyone in her
community making contact with CPS. Let me be clear. I have never
claimed that Denims called CPS. I have never implied that Denims
called CPS. If my statements were interpreted as stating this,
I want to correct the record and make it clear that I do not
think do not state that Denim called >> Hold on. You guys,
you guys are misunderstanding. You guys are misunderstanding.
You guys are misunderstanding
what he's saying here. This is after he received a cease and
desist. He did this to avoid litigation,
right? This is him uh basically being told by Denims, I will
have to sue you if you don't retract the idea that I committed
a crime. If you don't say that you were wrong in this, this is
not the same thing. This is very different. Okay. He's literally
saying the opposite of what's true because he has to say this.
This is how you avoid getting sued for defamation in the States.
>> Yes. obviously moronic, idiotic, stupid.
Let [snorts] me also address the point in the letter that I claimed
Denim caused others to call CPS. I did not state and I do not
believe Denims made a direct call to action to our audience to
contact CPS. Obviously, >> yeah, this is this is lawyer
speak because he got hit right. >> He got hit with a CND,
I assume, under third of a lawsuit while appearing to read a
letter from his lawyer. Ethan Klein attempts to formally retract
the three defamatory claims against Denims. Ethan admits Denims
didn't call CPS. Didn't denounce those that called CPS. Never
made a call to action for another to call CPS. Okay. Except he
literally did do that for the record. Okay. He did. It's like
very clear what Idubbbz is doing. It's twofold. One, uh, at that
point, uh, Ethan was just like constantly clipping his streams
to like, yeah, dunk on him. So, he he thought that this would
be a defensive shield against Ethan, uh, most likely clipping
his streams. And two, it is a defamatory statement. It's a ridiculously
defamatory statement. And yet Ethan was not even remotely invested
in addressing that defamatory statement at all and instead did
the unthinkable and went after Idubbbz for literally disavowing
the defamatory statement.
>> Defamatory.
I don't know why he's saying it weird.
>> He literally said she did CPS with time
>> Bro, you're so smug. >> He did say he did. >> He
did CPS. Remember that. Okay, good. >> Right now one's
a little bit more. >> Yeah, he just That was his rallying
cry for the longest time. Uh she did CPS. He did CPS. They all
did CPS. Everybody and their mothers. Everybody that has ever
criticized Ethan Klein has been Did Hassan react to the H3 stream
from yesterday? Cuz that one was particularly bad where he accuses
Idubbbz of saying that that E. He says, "Idubbbz said my kids
were better off in foster care than with me." That's a That's
a level to which he victimizes himself. Idubbbz actually said
my kids would be better off in foster care than with me. I'm
pretty sure Idubbbz didn't say that, man. I come on. I'm pretty
sure he didn't say that. It was implied.
But when he said, did he say like CPS should be called? No. He
said I might have contributed to CPS getting called. Yeah, that
doesn't track at all, man. I don't know what to tell you, Ethan.
That doesn't track. That doesn't make any >> Been responsible
for uh calling child protective services on his children. It's
ridiculous.
>> It's despicable that he would think it's a good idea
to post that there while knowingly aware that it's not true.
So, the message isn't Ian's. This comes from Destiny. and he
found this screenshot and he kept it on screen for a very long
time. And he said he didn't agree with it but thinks it needs
to be addressed because it's so up. It is a terrible stream.
Just giving it to you real blunt, real raw. It is no good.
And >> it is no good. >> I'm no stranger to getting
[__] talked by Idubbbz. He has said some very nasty,
very untrue things about me on his broadcast as well. But what
is being reported in regards to this stream isn't exactly telling
the whole story ultimately. I I don't think we fully saw eye
to eye on this, which you know that's going to happen. I fully
understand that this is a very emotionally charged subject for
him after everything him and his family went through with snarkers
in particular. I know what these have to do with this, bro. This
is literally this is literally the most Israelcoded story of
all time,
It's literally but the snarkers. Snarkers have become the butt
hamas of Ethan's universe. Okay. Oh, sorry. We're just gonna
do uh you know, we're gonna do a eightfront war or in this it
just gets Dude, I'm sorry.
I understand why they think we're like coordinating.
It's just obvious on its face. It's just all of this is obvious
analysis on its face. I get that it seems like there's coordination.
I get that it seems like, oh my god, these guys are all saying
the same thing. They must all talk to each other. No, this is
just like obvious to anybody who's paying attention. circumstance
a five legal war >> with anyone and everyone around us
>> wait is Han saying that the most Israeli thing the one
nation is a fivefront legal warers called CPS on us like what
do you mean what the [__] does that have to do with
anybody else >> that the [clears throat] CPS and the human
souls incident are like a legitimately traumatizing thing like
the fraudulent CPS call like I I get how inexcusable and abhorentt
that is I really do >> yeah imagine if you got the treatment
commentary community Reddit main media
we are
babying this 40-year-old
multi-millionaire with with potentially upwards of hund00 million
in his bank account that he's using
to to legally go after much smaller channels with no financial
backing whatsoever
because CPS
like it just doesn't make any sense.
Oh my god.
Maybe, maybe, dude, I hate to say it, but maybe real discourse
can share the same script because I swear I swear I'm not giving
this guy talking points right now, okay,
this time. But it's it's all the same things. It's like, dude,
I didn't watch this. I didn't watch this. I had no idea he was
going to say these things. >> He's obviously crazy, man.
What is this like like this babying that this guy How many lawsuits
is he allowed to have under his belt until people go, "Okay,
maybe this is a bridge too far." Like how many random people
that he is annoyed with on the internet that he is just like
trying to bury under a mountain of paperwork with costly litigation
until people go, you know, maybe that's not appropriate. Only
Diaz said to call CPS, by the way. Yeah. >> Yeah. The only
person, ironically enough, out of all these people that Ethan
Klein is suing that has actually openly defended calling CPS.
>> Oh, he's got the clips >> on Ethan Klein's children
is Sex >> I hope CPS makes his kids. I'll say it. I do.
I hope they >> Hey, I know I know that Mail Slayer account.
They retweet a bunch of my love that it see for my kid and then
see if you guys can take the dance cuz kids. You know what? All
of our children at the end of the day will just be fostered by
child protective services. Okay. And that'll just be and then
we can all
relieve ourselves. He's just going to be a rehash of all the
every other video made. God, it's so crazy how this um as he's
spamming on Instagram and coughing and dying of whatever diseases
he has is is is telling me like, "Oh, Jesse, I used to like you
so much and you need help and blah blah." It's like the the exact
the exact was doing to him.
[sighs] Good me.
this new video couldn't be um complete without random assignment
mention of >> but I [clears throat] just truly don't believe
that this lawsuit is in any way. >> Okay, I'm not going
to throw the first stone on that one. I'm not Listen, I bring
up other people all the time. I feel like does too helpful to
anyone outside of the lawyers. They're smiling ear to ear. They're
salvating right now. Literally drooling. If >> I'm covering
some sort of like, you know, consent violation, I'm probably
going to mention Destiny once in that stream. I'm sorry. It's
just it's going to come up naturally. My bad. with a bib on butful
to I think literally everyone involved and does have potential
ramifications for others way outside of it. I have never and
will never be a fan of extreme litigation and I have always been
vocally advocating against creators going that nuclear path and
I always will of course there are cases where it is understandable
like I said going after the snarkers that sent a fraudulent CPS
thing through and the skulls and stuff that one I do >> bro
but what does that have to do with Idubbbz? I mean, where is
the veracity or where is the
genuine proof that there is again a network of like anonymous
accounts that Ethan Klein has targeted and identified as being
responsible for calling child protective services on him? I don't
even think there is any proof whatsoever. Ethan certainly doesn't
have that. I don't know why he keeps bringing this up as though
it has anything to do with Idubbbz anyway.
But
it's in the It's in the Discord logs. It will be in the Discord
logs eventually. It will come out. It's in the Discord >> I
could never support that. And I I just can't see the real just
cause behind it. And I think it is a terrible example for other
creators in the space to follow where maybe they believe that
even though this is about like a Canadian defamation lawsuit,
well, maybe they can try their luck in the States. You know,
it's not like defamatory lawsuits are exclusive to Canada. There's
better protections here, no doubt. But still, if they take from
this that maybe the way to fight battles online is to go the
latigious route, well then it's just a huge mess across the board.
I think it is just a >> Yeah, bro. I'm telling you, if
you want the entire commentary sphere to finally pay attention
to this, I know the solution. I have to sue one of my >> He
knows the solution. He knows what he has to do. He has to [laughter]
I I can't say it cuz the solution is funny.
He's just got to pick like a random nobody streamer or Twitter
account. Dude, no. Hold on. He knows the Wait, not that kind
of solution. No, Klein Healing. No, no. I was going to say he's
Stardust once covered a random Destiny streamer Destiny defamed
Hison and now Stardust will be sued. Okay, Stardust will be sued
immediately. >> You know, thousands of insane haters on
the internet.
>> And I I'll be real at least if it's for her commentary.
I would nobody can sue Stardust until I sue Stardust for never
ever transforming a single piece of content she's ever watched.
Okay.
I would I would defend Stardust on that one. Unfortunately, it
would kill me to do it, but I would.
>> Here's E denying that you uh to you that he never said
anything >> that harassment and you pulled it up on your
stream. >> You have evidence that HB Snark called CPS on
you. >> Did I say that? >> Did I say that? I said
their primary response were harassing me. >> Who called
CPS? >> What the [__] So, I don't know. >> Did
I claim they did? You're dodging, bro. You are absolutely dodging.
You claim your community has nothing to do with the harassment.
Yet, you were browsing H3. Now, let me ask you this. Who? How
many times? >> Yeah.
So, what's all this lawsuit about?
What's all this lawsuit about?
I mean, here he is admitting that he has no evidence whatsoever.
Should have ended there, right? Seems to me like you got an unfathomably
rich guy who was just mad that people have turned on him on the
internet. And instead of trying to figure out why that took place
and maybe changing his goddamn behavior, he's decided to bury
all of the people that have dared to criticize him under costly
litigation while simultaneously claiming falsely that they were
responsible for child protective services being called to his
house. He literally said this about Snark CBS yesterday. Yeah,
I know. I'm not going to read that, man. I'm sorry. >> A
very bad precedent. >> Too long, didn't read. >> You
know, the lawsuit doesn't end in a victory for him. This way
of engaging with discourse, I think, has always been frowned
upon, but for some reason is starting to get some more support
behind it. And I just fully disagree with it. I think that this
is genuinely just a like big threat across the board to just
the entire space. Like, if discourse becomes, you know, fearful
of like litigation flying back and forth, it's going to stifle
a lot of voices and stifle some very like legitimate criticism
down the line. It's just not something I want to see.
I must have missed that. Listen, Charlie loses me to sleep sometimes,
so I must have missed that precise point during his thing. This
will obviously chill legitimate criticism. Even if you're trying
to to distinguish it, it won't matter. It will chill legitimate
criticism and almost certainly of the people who most need criticism
of people with a lot of wealth, right? The ability to use the
legal system, bend the legal system to their whims. Those are
the people who need to be criticized and those are the people
who have criticism against them chilled. Going after somebody
with no money to sue anyone, that doesn't that's nothing.
That that like sorry going after somebody with no money to sue
anyone that doesn't take any courage at all, right? Suing somebody
with some actual sway, with some actual clout, with some actual
power, money, that is something that you could be scared of.
And if suddenly every one of these YouTubers is suing anyone,
criticizing them, something everybody's going to be scared of,
every smaller creator at least,
it will offens it will effectively freeze out like the bottom
like a a huge chunk of the bottom level creators. You'll have
no new turnover. It'll just become frozen. And I think that's
why some of the biggest content creators, by the way, don't want
to talk about it. Don't want to criticize, don't really want
to get involved.
They're fine with things being oified. They're fine with things
getting frozen. They're fine with things being set in stone.
They don't want turnover, right? They want to have They want
to be able to show up and not do any work. Just show up like
Charlie is right here. Hi guys. Well, Charlie actually did some
work for this one, so it's a little unfair, but for a lot of
Charlie's other, right? Hi guys,
I'm Charlie.
Welcome to the video for today. I don't really spend a lot of
time online anymore.
Like it. Come on, man. >> See become common place. Now,
I did also have a brief conversation with Idubbbz about this
as well, letting him know that this really is a horrible thing
that he did to try and make his point. And he agreed. He said
that it was a legitimately awful thing that he did to make that
point and that dog, but the offending party is not even being
mentioned here. No one is saying there isn't an offense being
made, but it's not Idubbbz that is the offending party. It's
destiny.
and it was a genuine sincere apology that he was issuing and
how regretfully he was from it. So, I did have a conversation
with both sides of this to make sure I had like a full clear
picture of where everything was and what this was all about.
>> I don't I don't know how it works in Canada if the complaint
is public or what, [snorts] but if you look at it, he um emphasizes
throughout that he does think it's a serious accusation that
needs to be investigated and that he doesn't think it's a joke.
Right. Um now, I know >> Yeah, he has no basis for this
by the way. Like I don't know how ridiculous Canadian defamation
laws are, but like there is literally no standing
Like this would be laughed out of court in the United States
of America. That's why he didn't file this in California. He
get hit with a slap so fast his face would spin. >> I think
that's going to happen. No, I really hope that happens with Noah
Samson, too. So, that's the hope. Idubbbz is American. He currently
lives in Canada with his wife's family. I
I think I think Ana's dad is actually like ill. Like I think
he's got Alzheimer's or something. And so, I think they moved
back probably as much to take care of them as it was to like
move back for financial reasons. I I don't necessarily believe
that Idubbbz doesn't have any money anymore.
Like I I can't imagine they're like broke broke to be honest
with you.
I just can't. But
but I do think they move back to take care of Ana's dad who's
ill, right? Am I
>> Oh, people people are like, "Well, why didn't you Destiny?"
They're saying it. Well, Destiny made [snorts] it immediately.
First of all, this is a comment from Destiny, like made in passing.
Ian put it on his screen for two hours during his main broadcast.
Destiny made it clear that he was not being serious, right? >> Did
he? Did he? >> Oh, okay then.
>> Pretty much immediately after writing it. Like nobody
was like made this claim that Ethan his children. Hoes. No. People
knew that when Destiny said it was like it was he was just being
a [__] or I mean he was being a giant piece of [__]
right? But he immediately afterwards made it clear that he didn't
actually think that. But Ian took that. And just because you're
showing what someone else said doesn't make it not defamation
cuz you're showing essentially uh this accusation bear of context.
and um
and also kind of saying that you think it's true right >> now.
After hearing Ethan explain that, I actually made >> Wait,
first of all, no, the context of it was that he's pissed off
that you were calling him a >> Was Destiny joking here,
too? >> This clip, by the way, >> cuz it wasn't a
one-off. Yeah, Destiny's version of getting great excuse to be
petty to whoever somebody else. Yeah, here he is again. Okay,
never mind. Take back what I said about Ethan. Maybe he is a
pedo. What is >> he has to tie back to me
trying to tie people back to me. Like I said, that's why I call
them kids or whatever. It's because Ethan gave him because he's
a spless hack to this type of attack. He's like, "No, I'm not
like >> incredible stuff, man. Ethan is lying. Destiny
instead admitted actual malice, which is required to sue for
defamation of public figures.
>> that's such a dude. That's such a Hassanism. That's
like PBD being a numbers guy. Hassan reads something from his
chat like a like somebody explaining what's actually happening.
So like Destiny sued Destiny is actually admitting the actual
malice here which is required to sue somebody who's a public
figure.
Incredible stuff. Again, it just doesn't make any sense. It's
so stupid. >> Good times. Good times. >> It's so
unbelievably stupid that even the average person when they find
out the details go, "Wait, what the
>> I'm sorry. Now I'm even more confused." So, Destiny
said that the climate's kids and passing comment is fine because
Destiny said he's getting ite showing it on screen is bad despite
him explicitly saying that he doesn't agree with it. Doesn't
make any sense. It doesn't because it has nothing to do with
making sense and everything to do with the fact that Ethan wants
to punish people who uh have have criticized him in the past.
That's it. because he's a thin-kinned narcissistic multi-millionaire
who's paranoid as hard to pay attention to someone who speaks
with their mouth full. It's pretty disgusting.
Cool. I'm I'm going to eat food in like 10 minutes. So, good
luck. Good luck with that, man. Luck with that, buddy. Okay,
now guys, if you like the content, go ahead. Throw a couple subs
my way. We are 52 minutes. We have 52 minutes left on the stream.
We have what is it? Five six subs. Six subs from another hour
on the stream right now. Get those subs in so we can keep going.
We've got the Hassan stream. We've got some of the Fentano stuff.
Uh Fantano stuff. And what else do we got? Oh, we'll have the
whole bricks and miniigs thing for later. So, let's go. Watch
your back. Thank you for the 100 kicks. >> And it's so
funny because a different reason here. >> Check your kicks,
too. I have checked my kicks. My kicks are at they were used
to pay for the first hour of the stream.
>> You want to know something even crazier? I'll tell you
something even crazier. He has to make excuses for Destiny because
Destiny's podcast co-host and best friend is a 60-year-old weirdo
by the name of Dan Stalkman who owns the company redact.dev.
redact.dev is one of the last remaining Whoa, WHOA, WHOA. I GOT
TO FACT check us on here.
Dan is in his 40s.
Okay. I think somewhere in his 40s. I don't know exactly, but
not 60. See, please don't sue me, Dad. Please don't sue me, Dad.
Look, I I just corrected misinformation on you. Dan is in his
40s, okay?
Not He is not 60. He is not 50. He is in his 40s.
Okay? I look I just I just fixed the misinformation.
>> Sponsors of Ethan Klein's company.
Hash don't sue me
Israeli man. Well, American Israeli man.
Don't sue me, Dan. Thank you. >> Dan and Destiny have wrapped
Ethan around their goddamn fingers and use him like a flashlight.
So he can't even
unlucky. Unfortunately for Ethan, this is just true. And Ethan
will fight against it. He will hate it. He will not want to admit
it. It's just true. It's like objectively true. Sorry, Ethan.
Sorry, man. >> Even turn around and [__] on
them because that's a lifeline for his business. So remember
that [__] I mean, come on. This is pretty basic stuff,
by the way. Uh like I'm sure Charlie didn't know any of this
and no one's going to tell him this, but it is like it's it's
basically just a like it's basically just requires you to scratch
the
The idea that there is no like financial entanglements between
Destiny and and Ethan Klein is crazy. There's a direct conflict
of interest, which is part of the reason why he can't turn around
and sue Destiny. He's too to do this. Sure, he doesn't like Destiny
any longer. Or maybe Destiny has made inroads with him again
by attacking his enemies again like a pitbull. I think the the
thing they're all breaking bread on right now is the the snarks
discord or whatever. I think that's what they're breaking bread
on, which was the reason why they were initially aligned with
one another.
It's crazy that there's no there's no principled statement here
and it's all just like coalitions.
Yeah, there's no there's no principled stance that people are
taking here. I mean, I guess Moyes is kind of taking a principal
stance here, even though he's like hitting the the peak of the
center of the argument when it's a lopsided, totally one-sided
argument in my opinion. And he will obviously at the end side
with with Idubbbz because it's totally ridiculous as he's reiterating
over and over again. >> Now, while Ethan is 100% correct
that Idubbbz says that this is a big allegation that Ethan should
be addressing, he's not doing it earnestly, or at least I don't
think he was. It's actually really kind of hard to tell. The
whole segment was awful. And the point he was trying to make
was really dog shittily done. But what he's trying to say is
that clip right there at the end where >> it's so funny
because Destiny has literally operated. We know Destiny has literally
operated alongside Dan Stalkman, Ethan Klein's biggest sponsor,
a mass harassment Discord server where they dxed my whole family.
We know this. I've shown this on stream before. So like everything
that Moisty Critical is claiming Ethan is actually pursuing litigation
over, I have direct evidence that these [__] were
doing. Destiny said this extremely outrageous, outlandish, disgusting
thing about Ethan, and yet Ethan doesn't have smoke for him,
but he does for the other people that he's gone after through
lawsuits. I'm pretty sure that's the point he was trying to make
by putting that on screen. Like, look, Destiny has said something.
Absolutely. >> Wait, what do you mean? You're pretty sure
that's literally the clip that you
>> That is Yeah. He hedges in the weirdest way. He like
proves something objectively. Mo Critical does that he's like
I'm pretty sure that this happened. He like [laughter] watches
like the tape one to one. Unless I've blanked out and like erased
moments from my memory from this segment. I don't recall him
saying that this is like a serious thing he believes in is and
is presenting it as such like about Ethan is this and this is
a real allegation that really has a lot of water to it. Now,
this doesn't change the fact that what Idubbbz did here is completely
awful. To try and make this point using that kind of comment
with something as monstrously evil as that is just so low, >> but
I don't believe Ethan is
Yeah. See, I didn't fight back against this. I do think it's
wrong,
but I I don't fight back against this because I think that hedging
allows other people to hear that like it allows them to
right? Like it it's not true that it's like totally disgusting.
I think it's a fine point to make and I think that was the the
comment to use to make that point, but I do think it allows the
the culty people to offramp, which is kind of nice. Okay. I think
this is just uh moral posturing. What do you mean?
Idubbbz is not in agreement with the comment whatsoever. I think
it's perfectly valid to use such a severely defatory statement
like that one which ironically enough is made about me as well
because he's a psycho to be fair everybody calling everyone on
the internet nowadays it turns out I think it gives a lot of
cover to actual I think you should have some actual argument
but hey it is what it is >> if you are a latigious person
if you're a latigious person you should apply that latigious
nature to the actual offending party rather than whoever you
actually want to punish and punish financially,
not because you're going to be able to win that court case, not
about victory in this circumstance. It's about just, you know,
costly litigation,
burying people under a mountain of >> explaining it to
everyone where Idubbbz is really, you know, believing in this.
Idubbbz came over to my house. He met my family. Now he's going
out there saying these things.
if Charlie
if Charlie knew half the gross Ethan Klein has said about Ian
and Anissa,
I don't think he'd be doing this. Ethan Klein direct. >> He
wouldn't be he wouldn't be. He still he is recently, you know,
the amount he was following it. He has the prevailing opinion
which is the wrong opinion which is factually incorrect which
is that Ethan is the sorry Ethan is the eternal victim here.
He's had like totally crazy done to him and never done anything
to deserve it. That's the prevailing opinion and he he's going
with it and ultimately he's breaking from the prevailing opinion
in a way that is consequential. And so I don't I don't hate it
that much. I do think it's I said the same I think I said as
much as did here which is if he hadn't hedged like this like
or if he had looked into it more if he was even remotely aware
of all the facts he would not he would not be saying this it's
just not really commensurate with reality >> stalked and
mass harassed
Idubbbz and Anissa directly for months on end this litigation
is an extension of that
Klein has also called people that he doesn't like Nazis photoshopped
photos on his Instagram stories to imply that they're Nazis.
He's done it to me, too.
He has called people that he does not like, including Dan Clancy,
the CEO of Twitch.
Remember, Ethan edited the mine comp on on a photo that Anise
had posted, and claimed it was the original one. He posted a
fake story, apologized, and deleted it, then posted a worse edit.
Oh,
I didn't even know about this one. is extremely scummy because
he did meet his kids and everything and now he's putting a comment
out there like that. That is very scummy. But he's not using
it to try and make this claim that Ethan is those things. He's
trying to use that to >> Dude, dude, dude, dude. Who's
the scumbag here? Is it Idubbbz or is it the guy who's been harassing
Idubbbz and Anissa for months? I'm sorry, dude.
Come on, Charlie. I know everybody hates Ian and my >> I
I'm just going to say you're a scumbag once once you take it
past the content like they as far as I'm concerned Idubbbz was
doing content that was fully within the bounds of the dynamic
they'd set up of the frame that they'd set up that he he was
not doing something to massively escalate there that wasn't some
kind of massive escalation it was totally in line with all the
content they've done on each other right and Ethan was the one
who went oh I don't like that nope there I'm suing you Now,
honestly, to me, I don't care about Ethan covering their everybody
covering their so long as you just make it coverage, right?
Ana showed that as soon as she pushed back, all those people
like stopped, by the way.
But for for Ethan, he just decided to sue the second things went
away he didn't like, which is particularly egregious. I don't
know. It's particularly embarrassing. >> Myself and Morgan
and Casey Tron on the internet. Okay, but come on, dude. I mean,
he's taken stronger stances in the past defending trans people.
He's taken stronger stances in the past criticizing
I guess, in the commentary sphere being even in any way, shape,
or form remotely in defense of the truth, which happens to side
with Idubbbz or happens to side with Denims is is worse than
all of those things combined.
What is crazy? I don't know. Maybe this is Bro, is this guy this
guy's pretending he's never watched a denim stream and seen her
do that smug look at the camera and just felt the the misogynist
rage come up? I'm just saying I I always I will never claim I
don't understand why somebody hates Denims. I will. And as much
as I think Denims is like funny now, I find a lot of her stuff
like funny. Not a huge fan of the stream overall, but it's like
different tastes, whatever. I I I will never say I don't understand
why somebody like hates denims.
I I literally have to watch one time of her doing that stupid
smile, that smug smile. I'm just like, "Yeah, I get it. I get
it. I understand.
It's powerful smile." Okay. >> This is your opinion. I'm
willing to be charitable. Uh and I'm um you know, I'm willing
to be charitable and assume that it's coming from a place of
him not like fully researching this stuff. But it seems like
he's researched it extensively on one side. So he has tremendous
amount of insight into uh you know the grievances that Ethan
Klein has experienced or claims to have experienced even though
it doesn't
>> Hey I understand it so much I think I shut my computer
down once punching my desk. I think I went to slam my desk and
something you know something shorted in my in my tower and it
shut my computer off. I ended my stream out of nowhere. So that's
how much I understand it. Okay back. So even after hearing Ethan
side he still doesn't side with Ethan. So that that in and of
itself should show you how how how unbalanced this whole predicament
is. Yeah. Remember when you got caught
>> at a poker tournament zooming in on a picture of Anissa
and then screenshotting it and saving it
>> for talking about her.
>> Congratulations to the baby number one. >> Now
how tapped in is this on? Does he know that? That's the Idubbbz
Snark subreddit right there that Ethan is looking at. Ethan is
looking at Idubbbz Snark right there. I miss the old
>> Does he know that? >> Got both names ready. [laughter]
>> Congratulations to the
>> players. Baby number one. >> Everything's neutral.
Got both names
>> That's so funny. >> Destiny has said something
so terrible, yet you are not approaching him with the same energy
you have everybody else. That is the point he was trying to make,
I think, throughout that segment. At least from everything that
I saw when watching it. Granted, it was very hard to sit through,
but I'm pretty sure that's what he was trying to get at with
that there. But I think that was a terrible way of going about
it. Now, Ethan also addresses why he's not suing Destiny as well,
and he's saying because Destiny cleared up that he wasn't being
serious right away. I don't understand that. I'm not going to
lie. That's not making sense to me. Can't wrap my noodle around
it. It's not computing. I think it is. >> That's a lie,
by the way. That's a lie. He never cleared it up. He never lit.
He he he might have. Now
>> I think what they consider clearing up is him saying
he was doing it maliciously
as in like I know I he cleared it up by saying I was just lying
maliciously.
I I didn't think it was the case. I just lied maliciously cuz
he called me a I think that's what they're considering clearing
it up. >> He might have now, but at the time he certainly
was very pissed off and he's a very vindictive person and he
lies about people all the goddamn time. So no, at the time he
kept doubling down, tripling
>> Yeah. Here's another post about Ethan making a disgusting
comment about Idubbbz and Anissa. >> I mean loser. >> He
has a litany of like this. That's why I'm saying like >> dude
another another male slayer clip. Let's go.
Han really do be following these people on Twitter. Okay. Han
is a snarker at heart. Maybe maybe he is in that discord. Like
oh Idubbbz is a scumbag is a crazy thing to say. Idubbbz is a
scumbag for showing someone else's defamatory claims in an effort
to draw home a point that Ethan will never go after them because
he's financially involved with that group. >> Defamation
by actual definition. Yes, it is. It it literally is >> and
also ideologically involved with that group because he uses or
he thinks he uses uh Destiny's community as a as a cyber stalking
operation to harass his internet enemies is literally the point
that Idubbbz is making. What he's doing there is nowhere near
as bad as like half the [__] that Ethan says on a
daily base about Ian and about Anissa. Here is one of them. >> What
a dumbass.
Can't believe I felt bad for you. >> By the way, Ana reached
out. She wants to meet at the Motel uh 6 tonight at
>> Excuse me. >> Because I'm going to him for her
cuz she's the
>> No good. >> Okay. Ian [clears throat]
>> Ana reached out to me. [laughter] >> It's such
a weird clip. HE'S SUCH A WEIRD PERSON.
HOLY,
DUDE. I It was so funny reacting to this clip the first time
I saw it. Okay. He's like so
psychosexually obsessed and it's so funny, man. >> To me,
>> you know, the first time that you made the Ana the joke
really good. I feel like each subsequent one, we're getting we're
getting further and further. What was wrong with >> I like
that as soon as I started talking about Ethan and
and you know all this other [__] going on immediately
the weirdo Destiny fans come in here to be like damn Hamas calling
me Hamas and then saying I got fat. Nice. What's good? Nobody
ever said DJers missed the mark on what will actually irritate
the person. Okay. Nobody ever said that. You go into this guy's
chat, you say, "Hey, you getting a little fat now, aren't you?"
Bro, that's going to I'm sorry. Hassan is transparently just
like a very very superficial narcissistic kind of guy. Not not
hating. Not hating. Not hating at all. I'm just I'm just saying
that it's very obvious that that's what would irritate him. That's
what would annoy him. And they just immediately hone in. Oh,
you got a little chubby there, eh? He's not any He's still way
skinnier than he was like um 3 years ago or whatever. But it's
it's just funny that that's the one that's actually going to
stick with him. You're going to see a lot a lot fewer sandwiches,
more salads. Okay. more salads with protein
right. It's you're going to see if you just if you were obsessed
enough to track his lunch patterns, you're not going to see those
sandwiches getting delivered anymore with mayo on them, full
fat mayo. It's going to be salads with a lot of chicken in them.
You know what I'm saying? >> Um here, this is what I tweeted.
Um >> oh, if you're wondering why these serial defamers
never got sued by Ethan Klein, even though Epson, not Idubbbz,
is the one who initially claimed Ethan his children and double
down. It's because Dan Stalkman, the one who realizes he lied
to thousands of advertisers to trigger an apocalypse on Twitch,
has been a financial sponsor of Ethan Klein's podcast, Redact
Dev, in parenthesis. And they all support Israel and cyber stock
and harasses prominent critics online. Then has openly fielded
Congress people to try and deplatform me from my pro Palestinian
advocacy. Of course, there was never a pee from the YouTube commentary.
They mostly support it as terrorism support.
Dude, can you please see a psychiatrist? I swear Israel, aka
the isn't behind everything. At this point, you're either mentally
ill or you're knowingly manipulating the mentally ill. I will
support Israel and cyber. Okay, so the only thing she had any
criticism on, the only thing she gave any notes on was the Israel
thing.
Rest of it we take to mean is true. I guess there's the rest
of it is all unamiguously f true. But this one part, they all
support Israel. Actually, I'll have you know Destiny is Israel's
loudest critic.
Destiny is in fact Israel's loudest critic.
He is the best critic of Israel. Some say the only critic of
Israel.